[Music]
in misleading name news this was
submitted by mr. Rogers a man got locked
inside a 20 file fitness describes his
experience what didn't go out if they
closed 21 fitness clothes for what days
no like why they call themselves 24 hour
there's some that stay open 24 hours but
saw the clothes yes a mom actually do
clothes a different brand
sometimes LA Fitness wear a lot of them
are in LA that's true no should know
it's call you know hey dude there's so
many Mexicans that might need swear it's
a la Fitness we say we like looking good
okay so this man named Dan force so he
he's from Utah and after work he usually
goes to his local 24-hour fitness and
does some laps in the pool swim some
laps in the pool he didn't know this but
that particular 24-hour fitness had
recently changed their hours where they
will be closing from midnight to 4:00
a.m. what so he ended up posting on
Facebook and he captioned it he posted
three photos and he captioned it with I
am literally locked inside 24 Hour
Fitness right now they closed the doors
and went home while I was swimming my
laps in the pool doesn't the name
suggest that they stay open 24 hours
walking around trying to figure out how
to get out I called Sandy dispatch which
is the city he's and me they told me
they'd call back I called my wife she
said find a comfortable place to sleep
I'll get a stack of yoga mats and take a
nap on them wanna help you look really
happy though
she's practical alright yeah she's like
honey I'm already in bed just find
somewhere comfortable yeah so he said
that there was one exit but it had a
cute [ __ ] so he was afraid that if he
would sound the alarm cops to show up
and like arrest him for breaking and
entering is that a minority that come on
you're from Utah yeah
damn and you already called article
dispatch like they should know you're
coming not only that you just post it to
Israel like you prove that you were
locked in as well and what did you steal
a workout you think he was like
underneath the pool like when they like
check they're like no one's here right I
don't think David shag they see it it
goes 11:59 midnight [ __ ] yeah boom they
already have their key in the door yeah
yeah so luckily he didn't stay locked in
there for very long it was about two
hours I mean it could have been like
four out you know four hours of their
clothes he couldn't say two hours
somebody taking a power nap in the
[ __ ] car it just going back and
opening up and then all right so we gave
ours I mean Ralph doesn't say anything
on it close like to push it through if
you're the manager whatever it's like oh
yeah Oh - man I'm 10 to 12 4 to 6 you
know like yeah because they're saying
that oh so then 24 hour ended up
apologizing for their oversight they
said on behalf of 24 hour fitness we
apologize to mr. Hill and the
unfortunate experience he had at the 24
hour fitness sandy Club when it closed
Saturday evening
he ended up posting this photo like the
cops saying is like I'm free when he
went back to go work out
he brought a sign with him that
[Laughter]
go get a sign Frenchie did he like try
to get creative and he's like he's
[ __ ] put some filters on the we will
be in a different light to have a
different like the fluorescent light so
so he did caption that photo with so I
felt bad about any poor poor publicity I
may have cause despite all the fuss I
still love my 24 parentheses even if
it's now my 20 maybe this is a workable
solution oh that's good [ __ ] up he
should have said every time look at the
gym and get afraid it's too late man
probably like like gave him like 6
months free or socially backpack the
draft yeah I would hella felt the aux
cord and had that [ __ ] gym boys day I
would have had that [ __ ] bull me well
you would have thought a party was going
on the console of the camera who's all
anybody it's just me baby
turn it up Michelle with the weights it
is going you've never been able to play
your music in the gym oh that's so true
your meals at 4 hours straight I would
have been chilling ok I would try to
take shots from the swimming pool that's
true I would've been working out [ __ ]
don't every piece of equipment
right now they wipe it down before they
leave not gonna wipe it down when they
come back to just trying to catch some
[ __ ] no just give it to somebody else
this should name it however many hours
is open well I go to a 19-hour fitness
or 17 hour fitness because they're not
all 24 hours but they may they might
they might adjust it again like they
said there that was a 24 hour fitness
one but they say they adjusted it
because of usage don't reconsider
adjusting it if it says the name like
changing their mind when me and Nikki
were at in the Bahamas oh you said it
right this time how come that's wrong
are you okay I was supposed to say
Bahamas
yes so yeah we were in the Bahamas and I
got locked out I was walking tour I had
to go oh yeah the alcohol is expensive
on the door so I found a deal right of
course you did Oh walk you to it get
some cheap ass look how far away was
this it sounds like it's pretty it was a
walk it was like eight minutes away
right so I was like sick I can do this
unfortunately I am not good at maps from
navigation things you got lost I got
lost in the hotel Hotel 20 rooms what 20
room hotel yeah but it's like it's like
an entire block of the Vegas strip you
were - Steve okay oh no you're getting
flamed I'm not going down for this [ __ ]
is a gigantic [ __ ] hotel it even has
a casino in it was it Atlantis yeah and
so yeah so I walked out the side door
and then I couldn't get back in and I
was like oh [ __ ] because I wasn't ever
scared for myself I was never scared
that oh no I'm not gonna be back or
whatever
I prayed for Nikki I wasn't afraid for
Nikki oh I was mad pissed actually that
every hour that I was going to be stuck
out here is eating into the amount of
money that I pay
it's [ __ ] big oh and I'm you're
worried your deal is it stick so it's
your key fob beam didn't open the door
well no there was no key fob thing
outside so I walked out of a part of it
like on the side and I thought great
I'll be able to walk through this gate
and get to to where the liquor store is
not the case it was it was Lily wrapped
up in the chain and they had a bike lock
around it yes because they don't want
people from the outside coming in
through it [ __ ] no get up high 15 feet
are so then by the way I'm like barefoot
you're gonna walk to the store barefoot
yeah my people share everybody else has
shoes you know why because shoes were
created
well you don't wear shoes the places you
pose the wear shoes this [ __ ]
disrespectful to the planet my shoes
what if you're at leisure can't can't
you take our position absolutely you can
while you're sitting down
if you're walking to a [ __ ] discount
liquor store shoe should be used
did you hear what about this uh-huh so
uh-huh a liquor store is eight minutes
away from where I was at the time right
but to get back to my room was 15
minutes okay so go get my shoes so I was
like wait you wouldn't carry shoes with
you at all day no [ __ ] no you're in my
privilege if I've ever heard it you're
at a resort that flames carrying him
water slide - a lazy river - [ __ ]
drinks and [ __ ] okay you still own a
safe facility yeah so like the drinks
the discount drinks they weren't like
down a road like in a different place
that was just on a different part of the
facility yeah but I'm pretty resilient
no you're not yes I am all the time
no you don't I do where's Nick you can't
leave she would say that you have a high
pain tolerance extremely yeah cuz wasn't
your like whole like kidney stone thing
yeah drives me [ __ ] crazy about you
guys you don't even listen to me I feel
like I express myself my feelings here
[Laughter]
about a month okay I had a hernia and I
did not know it for like a year
my guess will basically busted through
the lining of my stomach all right but I
didn't know what it was I thought it was
gasps oh oh I had it when I was a
starlight MC for Tough Mudder and so I'm
on a microphone for like eight hours
straight like doing all that yeah we're
gonna put your hands up out of this
literally 15 to 20 minutes like speeches
and they're like it's a five-minute we
said in the end I'll do it but so I'm
breathing like this and I'm just
thinking like oh man a gas or something
like that I had no idea it was to the
point where I was take boxes and wrap
them around my chest with like tape and
then put my tape top or anything cuz
like it was so pave weather but I
obviously didn't know what it was and I
didn't have a church yeah there's like
damn I come to hurt every day like my
stomach is killing me it then by the
next Monday would be good like as it
falls back in the ladder but like
basically what happens like your stomach
look busted that yeah it was a tearing
into a bus through and saw my intestine
would be like right here like through
the lines like slowly like I guess
hollering yeah your [ __ ] was whack could
he sound for a month no it wasn't a year
but I agree that is that is some tough
ass even more than that I've been black
my whole life so what I have to do pain
tolerance whoa
that's the whitest shits ever said
[Music]